Hey youtubers it’s charlie, I hope you guys
have all had an awesome holiday week.
I’ve been doing so many wholock videos I
didn’t want to let New Year’s creep by
without inviting the Walkers.
So we just got news that there will be another
major character death in the second half of
walking dead season 4 so I thought it would
be fun to try and guess who it’s going to
be.
To be clear, this isn’t coming right away
and it’s going to be very hard to top the
two major character deaths from the midseason
finale but it does help us narrow the list.
And a big heads up, if you’ve seen my Game
of Thrones kill list video, I’ll be doing
the same game for Walking Dead when it comes
back.
I’ll do a video explaining it before the
show comes back, but basically we just try
and guess who’s going to die first in each
episode.
And I give the winner a prize.
I haven’t decided what they’re going to
be yet, but be sure to subscribe if you’re
not already to participate.
Careful for spoilers for the comic books.
In order to talk about deaths we’ll have
to reference the comics because it’s become
like a game of thrones situation where the
tv story changes the book story.
So here’s my top 5 pieces of evidence about
who this WTF death is going to be.
Number 1 - Who’s safe?
Let’s talk about who it’s not going to
be first.
And that is Daryl.
Everyone breath a sigh of relief.
Norman Reedus already started talking about
how excited he was to get back and start filming
season 5.
Meaning he is returning.
In my mind, other than one or two other people
he would be the biggest character the show
could still kill.
Number 2 - Biggest person who was not in the
comics.
The biggest character who is not in the books
is Beth.
Number 3 - Who was feeding the rats.
We’re going to find out who was feeding
the rats.
The best theory I’ve seen is that it was
Lizzie.
Tyreese theorized that the same person who
was feeding the rats killed Karen and David.
That doesn’t mean lizzie will die, but here’s
where Carol comes back.
Number 4 - Carol Vs Tyreese.
Carol is coming back, we don’t know which
episode, but we do know that she’ll meet
up with Tyreese’s group.
Remember he ran off into the woods with Lizzie
and her friends.
And mostly likely baby Judith too.
We know that no one ever told tyreese about
carol confessing to killing karen and david.
But what if carol was just covering for lizzie.
What would tyreese do if he discovered the
truth and it turned out to be lizzie.
He probably wouldn’t kill her.
But he would try to banish her.
And carol would do anything to save lizzie.
Like killing tyreese to prevent him from hurting
her or sending her away.
Number 5 - It’s someone who’s still alive
in the comic books.
It’s an unconfirmed rumor but The biggest
characters on the show that are still alive
in the comics are Rick, Carl, Maggie and Michonne.
Of all those people the most heartbreaking
death I could imagine would be maggie.
Lauren Cohan wasn’t spotted on set when
they were shooting the second half of the
coming episodes this season.
And she hasn’t been very active on twitter,
which for her is unusual.
All these signs point to her dying or going
on a long trip off camera somewhere around
episode 12 or 13.
And the whole business with the rats, lizzie,
tyreese and carol could be misdirection for
the death of someone unexpected.
So based on the evidence here’s my list
in order from most likely to die to least
likely.
Maggie, Tyreese, Lizzie, Carol, Michonne,
Rick and Carl.
Let me know whether or not you think Maggie
will be the next big WTF death or if you think
it will be someone else.
There are a couple shows starting next week
including Sherlock Season 3, Community Season
5 and my anime club show.
So once we get past that I’ll post a video
explaining how my walking dead game is going
to work.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’m giving away one more twenty dollar amazon
giftcard to a random subscriber from the comments
even though this isn’t technically a wholock
week video.
Don’t worry though, if you haven’t won
anything yet, I’ll be doing weekly giveaways
for anime club starting this next saturday.
Right now click here to learn about my top
10 predictions for walking dead next year
and click here to start getting ready for
sherlock season 3.